where we left off in the last video
napoleon was doing pretty well in 1804
just as a bit of review he declared
himself emperor
emperor napoleon
napoleon
the first and then the whole last video
was about the third coalition that
formed in 1805 and we saw that at the
end of 1805 after the battle of
australis napoleon was able to crush the
third coalition crush
the
third coalition
which was mainly made up of russia and
austria this is all review we saw this
in the last video russia
russia and austria and the big byproduct
of that other than the fact that it just
made everyone think gee this napoleon
guy he's pretty formidable is that it
ended the holy roman empire which you
remember is neither holy nor roman nor
an empire it was really just a
collection of
german-speaking states but it ended
it ended the official holy roman empire
holy
roman
empire and napoleon felt so good about
himself at this point especially after
crushing the the austrian and russian
forces in australia that he had the ark
the triumph which if you go to if you go
to paris right now it's one of the
things you should see he had this built
and now it's to commemorate all of the
soldiers who have died for france but it
was
originally built by napoleon to orca or
it was commissioned by napoleon to
celebrate his victory at australis so
this is the arc
arc the my spelling is always a little
weak but it's especially weak when i'm
spelling something in french
arc de triumph
and that's right there so napoleon was
was doing pretty well
now on the other side of the equation
you could imagine that the other
major powers of europe were kind of
licking their wounds they were
they weren't sure what was going on and
they were starting to feel threatened
and in particular
this guy started to feel especially
threatened this is frederick
this is frederick
frederick once again my spelling is not
the strongest especially when i'm doing
something in german
frederick will
wilhelm
the third it actually took me a long
time to realize that wilhelm and william
are the same names that william is just
the english version of it but this is
frederick wilhelm iii and he is the king
of prussia he is
the king of prussia and he stayed out of
the action during the third coalition
and even now prussia is a major european
power and he gets threatened by this
rising power of napoleon who was able to
break up or almost take away austria's
influence from the holy roman empire and
now it kind of becomes you know becomes
this confederation of the rhine let me
show you the map
so this whole area over here
this whole area
let me make sure i'm dry this whole area
right well this all of this right over
here
these that which is now mainly modern
day germany that used to be the holy
roman
empire its emperor was the king of
austria who wasn't necessarily in it but
it kind of implied some type of
allegiance once he trounces once this is
france right here once he was able to
trounce austria in the in australia
austria and russia then this becomes a
confederation of ryan holy roman empire
let me
let me highlight this a little bit
better
so this general area holy roman empire
no longer exists and it now becomes kind
of a satellite region of france france
has a huge amount of control so you can
imagine that the king of prussia starts
getting a little bit threatened france
is on its borders it's a it's shown
itself to be able to defeat other great
powers with ease so this guy gets a
little paranoid whether he feels that
france might kind of uh threaten uh
prussia's power or maybe it's on the
other side of the equation that he just
didn't like this upstart who's not
related to all of the other
all of the other royalty of europe he
maybe wanted to put him in his place so
frederick wilhelm iii
declares war
declares war we're now in 1806. so we're
now in 1806.
we have prussia
prussia
declares
declares war
war on france and you're going to see
this pattern multiple times and the one
thing to kind of remember if you just
want to remember kind of major themes
we're always talking about the first
coalition second coalition third
coalition fourth coalition all of these
and it's always some combination of
britain and britain has kind of already
dominated the ocean so when we talk
about these these battles on land we're
not talking about britain much but this
whole time britain's in the background
trying to be a pain in france's neck
and then all of the other coalitions are
some combination of prussia austria and
russia and some other countries here and
there but you see one after another that
they keep challenging napoleon up to
this point and napoleon keeps trouncing
them takes more and more land and
territory and power from them and they
get even more insecure and then they
want to form other coalitions so this
happens again and this is the start of
the fourth coalition the last video is
the third then this is now
the formation of the fourth
fourth coalition and essentially the
coalition forms as soon as someone else
other than great britain joins the fight
because great britain is kind of in a
continuous war with napoleon over this
entire time period
so we've got this fourth coalition that
forms we've got prussia we've got great
britain and
russia wants to join the fight again so
as you can imagine the end of the third
coalition didn't keep russia out of the
fight for long so you also have so let
me write it down you have prussia
russia
and great britain there's always some
other actors but these are the major
ones
great britain and it was kind of silly
on the part of prussia because prussia
would have been in a much better
situation if it had helped the third
coalition maybe that would have changed
the outcome but now they're kind of
taking on napoleon at least initially on
their own because russia is always kind
of behind austria or pressure depending
which coalition you're talking about so
prussia and austria are always the first
line of defense in this case in the
fourth coalition it's prussia and they
get trounced
they get trounced in jenna ourstead let
me show you where that is so this is
actually napoleon getting the troops
together for at jenna arstead this right
here is is a charge of the french troops
there let me write this down
this is jenna
jenna
our stead
our
stead two cities close by each other in
germany
they're roughly
roughly around here i don't let's see
this map is a little difficult to read
but they're roughly in that area right
there they trounce napoleon once again
he trounces prussia so prussia's just
out of the way that's in that's in
october of 1806.
so this right here
this right here is in october and then
napoleon essentially chases the russians
through most of what's now poland
so he chases the russians through most
of what is now poland he has this hugely
bloody stalemate at a low i don't even
know how to say that it's right around
there if i'm if i read my maps correctly
so you stalemate
stalemate this is in this is in 1807
still made february 1807
at
at let me get the spelling right
e-y-l-a-u
super bloody they actually win the
battle but they aren't able to
decisively defeat the russian troops and
or the russian army in their estimates
that in that one battle there's anywhere
from 15 to 25 000 casualties on both
sides which is huge at that time i mean
even now you know if you think about
even modern wars that's a major amount
of casualties to have in just one single
battle
but napoleon persists and he's event
eventually able to decisively decisively
meet the russians at friedland which is
right about there
this is friedland
friedland right there that is in june
in june of
1807 and then there he's able to
decisively defeat the fourth coalition
so here we have we're at we're kind of
at the summer of 1807.
we're at summer of 1807 right here 1807.
we're talking about june is when
friedland occurs russians decisively
defeated the prussians were already
trounced several months ago and then
june and then in july of 07
july of
july of 1807
you have
france
signing the trees of tillset
the treaties
of tilsit and it's called the treaties
of tilsit instead of the treaty of
tilsit because he signed separate
treaties with russia and prussia at this
point napoleon had kind of lost all
respect for prussia and he wanted to
show it so he had a separate treaty with
prussia and a separate treaty with
russia the one with russia was a lot
more respectable it had all this
language about how napoleon and czar
alexander the one are now friends this
is this is tsar alexander one right here
this is alexander
one and as you'll see this friendship is
very temporary as you could imagine i
mean this was the guy napoleon defeated
australis not too long ago so you know
all this friendship should probably be
written in quotes but the treaty with
russia was very friendly and that's i
think napoleon still respected
still respected russia's power so
it you know friendly with russia
declared them it declared them allies
friendly
with
russia but it took but it kind of carved
up
the other treaty of tillset with prussia
carved it up
carved
up
prussia
and the main thing it did if we look at
this map here this is a map of central
europe or i guess you know the the
prussia and austria and france at the
end of the third coalition the main
thing it did it took the territory west
of the river elbe from prussia so this
is the river elbe
right here
that right there is the river elb the
blue is prussia after the third
coalition
so all of this stuff
gets taken away from prussia and most of
it turns into a french satellite kingdom
called the kingdom of westphalia
so this is part of the prussian treaty
of tilsit so you have the kingdom of
westphalia
kingdom
of west
failure
and to really emphasize it really is a
french satellite state and to add insult
to injury to the prussians napoleon puts
his brother jerome as king
so napoleon's
napoleon's
brother
jerome
jerome becomes king so it really is a
satellite state of france so here at the
end of this you know the other powers in
europe haven't learned that this europe
that this
that this napoleon character with this
grand arm this huge army that he's been
able to raise and his his military
tactics really is someone formidable to
deal with and so they keep you know
third coalition then they lose territory
then the fourth coalition then they lose
even more territory
and what happens at the end of this
fourth coalition and actually during the
fourth fourth coalition after napoleon
defeated prussia he realized gee you
know what i have i've either in direct
control or an indirect control in of a
significant part of europe and at the
same time he knew that britain had
complete domination of the oceans and it
was this kind of rouse rising industrial
power you know it was the beginning of
the
industrial revolution
so napoleon's ideas well you gee i can't
defeat russia on the on the waters i'm
sorry i can't defeat great britain on
the waters did i say russia now i've
been saying uh the whole point is is
that
great britain is dominant on the oceans
and napoleon realizes they can't he
can't invade great britain by sea he
can't
he can't do anything in the water with
great britain kind of pestering him so
what he tries to do is declare economic
warfare economic warfare in great
britain and he institutes
he institutes at the end he institutes
at the end of 1806 the continental
system so i'll put this right here this
is in november of 1806. so this is right
after he trounces the prussians that
jenner outstead jenna outstead so this
is in november
of 1806 where he's feeling really good
about his strength on the actual
continent he institutes what he calls
the continental system
continental
continental system and this is really
just a notion of economic warfare with
great britain that hey if you are either
part of the french pyre umpire
controlled by the french pyre or french
empire or aligned with the french empire
you embargo great britain this little
island
it controls the waters but it's
dependent on trade so napoleon's idea
through this continental system is to
embargo
embargo
the india the united kingdom of you know
we could call it great whatever we want
to call it embargo great britain
embargo
in bargo great britain and one thing he
got out of the russians this was
actually a huge concession because
russia was a major power at the time
he got them through the treaty of tilsit
to also
join the continental system
join the continental let me write that
in a color that will actually show up
join
the continental
continental
system and in return and he also got
some land some islands the ionic islands
off the coast the western coast of
greece and some some of the
some of the land off the dalmatian coast
let me show you right there so this area
over here
and russia in return and you know it's
pretty good because russia essentially
lost the war but in return they were
allowed to do whatever they want with
the ottoman empire and we'll talk more
about the ottoman empire in future
videos but if you want to have a general
view of what the ottoman empire is i
guess the the last the last remnant of
it is what is today modern turkey but uh
obviously it was a it was an empire at
that time but russia and the ottoman
empire were kind of at odds with each
other so it was great for russia to say
hey i'm going to be able to do whatever
i want with the russia with the ottoman
empire because before this napoleon was
was nominally aligned with the ottomans
so this was actually a big concession
for russia so at the end of this we have
a situation once again i guess the other
powers don't realize it
over and over third coalition napoleon
he he does you know he he really takes
care of the russians and the austrians
destroys the holy roman empire makes it
the confederation of the rhine under
napoleon's control prussia thinks you
know wants to put down napoleon declares
war again fourth coalition the only
byproduct of that is now
they lose this land napoleon becomes
even stronger and puts his king his
brother as king in the kingdom of
westphalia and now he has russia as an
ally to help his embargo on england so
really after after the end of the fourth
coalition a lot of a lot of historians
view this as kind of the height of
napoleon's power in in europe